it is August 28 2023 and you are
watching the code report terraform was
once the world's most loved open source
infrastructure as code tool but like
many successful Open Source Products it
sold out when it hit the big time a
couple weeks ago hashicorp announced
that they're switching all of their core
products including terraform to a BSL
license which officially stands for
open source license although
some people call it a business source
license it's been around since 2013 and
many other companies have adopted it
like famously mongodb elasticsearch and
redis it allows you to copy modify and
redistribute the code but commercial use
is only allowed under specific
conditions and in the case of hashicorp
you're not allowed to offer a
competitive service which means
terraform Bay Grant and all these other
products are no longer open source like
they were previously under the Mozilla
public license which allows commercial
use and distribution on one hand this
makes total sense because it prevents
giant companies like Amazon and Google
from taking the code that you've spent
years developing and offering it as a
paid service on their platform
essentially stealing your ability to
monetize it hashicorp is a public
company that ipo'd in 2021 and right
before the market collapsed and while
it's still growing the growth rate is
not spectacular for a tech company and
that's not good because they're also not
profitable and from a business
perspective it makes sense to lock down
their products so they're the only ones
that can monetize it this could affect
big cloud providers but also other
startups like spacelift that offer
terraform Services they'll be able to
continue offering services but won't be
able to incorporate any future releases
or security patches the problem though
is that this kind of feels like a rug
pole hashicorp invited everybody to use
its products under an open source
license and said hey everybody let's
make the world a better place together
but now in the middle of the race to
make the most money they're pulling out
a gun and shooting everybody in the
knees
thank you
the source code is still available but
that doesn't mean it's open source
because according to the open source
initiative true free and open source
software does not discriminate against
commercial Ventures terraform is now
what you would call Source available
software but this strategy could
backfire terraform is a great tool but
infrastructure as code is not nearly as
likely to cause vendor lock-in compared
to a database like mongodb or redis
because once your database is in
production you don't ever want to have
to touch it developer facing tools like
terraform though are far easier to
replace you've got open source tools
like ansible and palumi or dedicated
tools from cloud providers like cloud
formation and deployment manager and
you've also got cool new tools like SST
and the newly announced Wing language
which is a full-blown programming
language that can both provision
resources in the cloud and execute code
within those resources at the same time
the best part of this story though is
that the open source Community is not
just going to sit back and take it a
project called opentf originally posted
a Manifesto asking hashicorp to return
to the original license however because
those demands were not met they've now
announced a fork of terraform that is
truly open source course and will have
100 interop with future releases of
terraform but honestly it's just so rude
to undermine a billion dollar
corporation like that I can't believe
anyone would go to github.com opentf
Foundation Manifesto and click on the
star button I've already lost 70 on my
hashicorp stock and the more people that
go to github.com open TF Foundation
slash Manifesto then click on the star
button up here in the top right corner
the more likely it is that this stock I
got rug pulled on is not going to
recover do the right thing today and
support your local venture capitalist
and mega Corporation by not clicking on
the store button right here in the top
right corner at github.com open TF
Foundation Manifesto this has been the
code report thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one
[Music]